Alert!
You are attempting to view the file on SCP-001.
This file is highly classified, and its contents
are sealed by the order of the O5 Council.
By continuing to view them, you are confirming
that you have received prior authorization.
If you are found to be viewing these materials
without adequate clearance, you will be terminated.
If you choose to accept these risks, and verify
your credentials, access will be granted in
5...4...3...2...1.
The following is a truncated summary, based
on transcripts from an official meeting of
the O5 Council.
You have been warned.
O5-1 sat at a conference table, addressing
his colleagues.
All of the other council members looked at
him expectantly, except one.
"Hello everyone."
O5-1 began, "I'm sure you're all wondering
why Thirteen isn't here today.
I'll get to that, but first I want to publicly
address something I'm sure you've all noticed
by now.
After talking to you for the past week or
so, I've noticed that we've all been inducted
onto the Council almost at the exact same
time.
All of us, except Thirteen that is.
In fact, Thirteen probably conducted your
orientation."
The other council members nodded.
"It's good to know that wasn't just me," O5-2
commented.
"I would've expected the last Two to run me
through things."
O5-1 sighed.
"Indeed.
In fact, I asked Thirteen about it, but he
refused to say much.
Of course, he pled ignorance, but I don't
believe that.
As you might guess, the previous twelve O5s
did not retire at the same time.
They were killed.
In fact, this building isn't even the original
Site-01.
That was destroyed.
I think you can see where this is going."
O5-3 frowned.
"So, we have a dead O5 council, a missing
Site-01, and somehow none of this is on our
records."
"And only one suspect," piped up O5-2.
O5-1 held up a hand, drawing attention back
to his words.
"I would like to designate O5-13 as one of
our SCP-001 projects.
Of course, this will be kept secret from him,
but we need to investigate this entire ordeal
until we figure out what happened, how it
happened, and why O5-13 is the only one left
standing."
After the aforementioned conference, O5-13
was designated SCP-001.
SCP-001 is a male human of Latin American
descent, standing at approximately 1.9m tall.
The exact nature of this entity, and the anomalous
properties he possesses, are not yet known.
He was given his anomalous classification
following the Caesar Incident, an event that
resulted in the death of all previous O5 Council
members aside from 13, the complete eradication
of the previous Site-01, and the loss of any
official documentation on 13 or his appointment
to the Council.
SCP-001 is contained in a modified containment
facility constructed similarly to other Foundation
Sites, with the exception of additional living
arrangements for the members of the Overwatch
Council.
The facility is equipped with state-of-the-art
security cameras, as well as three nuclear
warheads intended as fail safes.
These will detonate if SCP-001 breaches containment.
One designated member of the Council is to
be given mnestic drugs on a regular basis,
and maintain official documentation of all
information gathered about SCP-001.
This Council member will be referred to as
The Archivist and will hold the position for
approximately four months at a time, though
they may terminate their duties sooner if
the mnestics' side effects prove too detrimental
to their health.
When a Council member's time as the Archivist
comes to a close, they must conduct a meeting
to assess what they have learned.
O5-1 was appointed to the role of inaugural
Archivist, and several months later, a second
Conference was called.
One of the subjects discussed was a series
of interviews conducted with survivors of
the Caesar Incident.
Though several members of personnel made it
out relatively unscathed, they had no memory
of the incident at all, and their interviews
were unfortunately of no help.
During the events of the conference, O5-10
revealed that he had recovered a copy of the
previous O5 Personnel Dossier.
It included an entry that described O5-13's
purpose on the council, stating:
"O5-13's special connection to the anomalous
gives him a perspective no other council member
could begin to fathom.
While Normalcy Confirmation meetings require
eleven members for quorum, no meeting is allowed
to proceed without O5-13's attendance."
In addition to this entry, there was a table
recording O5-13's various Anomalous Property
Measurements.
Perplexingly, his appearance, temperature,
skeletal structure, corporeality, and induced
emotional states were all found to be within
the baseline of normality.
The remainder of the conference was dedicated
to deciding the next steps for a series of
specialized teams looking into the Caesar
Incident, SCP-001's Origin, and the entity's
anomalous properties.
O5-8 was selected as the next Archivist, and
the meeting disbanded with a new sense of
purpose.
The Caesar Incident Team managed to identify
the geographical location of the previous
Site-01 by searching for records of unusual
seismic activity on the date of the incident.
Earthquake records led them to an island off
the coast of Greenland, where the remains
of the Site were waiting.
An investigative team attempted to search
the island, but was prevented from exploring
the ruins by representatives of the Global
Occult Coalition, who demanded they leave
immediately.
Investigation into the presence of the GOC
on the island turned up a curious connection:
their representatives had spoken with O5-13
before setting up an outpost there.
Meanwhile, the Origins Investigation team
looked into records of O5-13 at various Groups
of Interest.
Reports were conflicting and difficult to
parse, and the team brought their findings
to the third Conference.
Notice from O5-8:
"Conference #3 was cut short after an intense
exchange led to enough people leaving the
meeting for us to lose quorum.
We archived all of the material covered up
to that point, as well as the efforts made
to de-escalate tension between the members.
However, this also means that information
herein was not properly vetted by the entire
Council before being uploaded, so we erred
on the conservative side.
If you need to see the full proceedings, please
contact the current Archivist."
Before the premature adjourning of the conference,
the following conversation took place:
O5-1: Excuse me, Four.
I believe some clarification regarding the
exchange with Marshall, Carter, and Dark is
necessary.
O5-4: How so?
O5-1: It mentions here that you performed
an exchange.
It is important for the records, and for our
general information security that we know
exactly what information was exchanged.
O5-4: Yes, that does make sense.
I'm sorry, I did not write that section of
the report.
O5-10: If my memory serves me well, Seven
was responsible for the Marshall, Carter,
and Dark reconnaissance.
O5-1: Well, Seven, could you elaborate?
O5-7 looked at O5-1 and swallowed.
O5-11: You know, the rules are pretty tight
on this.
Why did you give them anything in the first
place?
O5-3: Eleven makes a good point.
Don't we have our own spies working some of
the transport routes?
O5-7 nodded and then began going through her
belongings.
O5-3: Could you at least tell us what kind
of information you gave them?
O5-7 paused, thought to herself for a moment,
and then motioned to the entire Council.
O5-11: Wait, you gave them information about
us?
O5-7 shook her head, paused again, and then
nodded her head yes.
She held up a finger and then went back to
looking through her files.
O5-11: But that's— No.
I don't believe this.
We can't let people know about us no matter
the situation.
Imagine if word got out that the old Council
had been killed.
I bet cults across the planet would have a
hay day.
O5-4: I doubt that she said anything actually
important.
O5-11: Oh really?
I've only dealt with the merchants once or
twice, but they know how to appraise anything,
especially information.
O5-7 held up an index finger and then continued
looking through her files.
O5-11: Are you just going to ignore the issue
then?
Just going to hang us out to dry?
O5-8: Eleven, you need to calm down.
O5-11: We're all waiting on you.
[under his breath] Dumb bitch.
O5-7 looked up at O5-11 and then put her files
away.
She gathered her things and left the room.
O5-11: Can't take being called out, I see.
O5-1: Eleven, I will need to speak with you
following this meeting.
O5-11: You can talk to me now.
I'll be in my office.
O5-11 left the room.
O5-4: Eight, I'd like to go after Seven to
make sure she didn't actually do something
stupid.
O5-8: That's fine.
I believe that would drop us below quorum,
but I believe this meeting has fallen apart
anyway.
One, Twelve, and I will make the next update
ourselves.
This SCP-001 Conference is dismissed.
Addendum.
An update has been added to this file by O5-8,
regarding security concerns:
"Following the official ending of the meeting,
O5-7 distributed the summary of all information
exchanged with Marshall, Carter, and Dark.
The information was pulled from the out-of-date
O5 Dossier.
The current explanation as to why it was accepted
by the Group of Interest is that it would
have confirmed any information they had gathered
previously about the O5 Council.
As part of the exchange we have received a
tip as to where to find more information on
SCP-001, which the Origins Team will investigate
for the next conference.
O5-7 later clarified in a written statement
that she had left the meeting simply to retrieve
the file detailing this information, since
it was not on her person.
O5-7 insisted that she does not need an interpreter,
due to information security concerns.
A discussion was scheduled between her and
O5-1 to reduce communicational issues at a
later date.
O5-11 issued a formal apology.
I hope that this will be the cessation of
any internal conflicts.
We are working together, and therefore require
that a trusting relationship has been established
between all members.
As Abraham Lincoln once said, "A house divided
against itself, cannot stand."
O5-12 was appointed to the position of Archivist,
and after several months passed, a fourth
conference was called.
The following is an excerpt from this meeting:
O5-12: Two, why doesn't your team start us
off.
O5-2: Alright, sure.
We did make some nice progress.
O5-8: Always good to start a meeting on a
high note.
O5-2: You all remember those four survivors
we talked about last meeting, right?
We got back in touch with them and did a more…
thorough interview.
More intense techniques, lie detector tests,
heart rate monitoring, the whole shebang.
O5-3: Do you have transcripts?
O5-2: I do but, spoiler-alert, they're not
very different from the first round.
O5-9: So, we're now convinced they genuinely
don't remember.
O5-11: How far does Thirteen's antimemetic
side reach?
O5-2: Slow down there.
We're not quite done.
You see, as part of our second round of interviews,
we also did a physical examination and some
tests to see what messed with their heads.
And we found they all had a little scar, right
on the side of their necks.
Right where we inject amnestics.
O5-8: I mean, while I understand what you're
implying, we tend to administer amnestics
fairly liberally.
Last meeting was essentially just a prolonged
reminder of how much we value InfoSec.
O5-2: True, but we keep good records of who
we use with that stuff, how much we're using,
if we're using the pills or the syringe, etcetera.
However, when I went to look up if any of
our "survivors" had ever taken the injectable
amnestic, all my results came back negative.
O5-6: I also took the liberty of checking
out Red Right Hand.
The entire squad's got injection scars, and
we rarely wipe those guys.
O5-2: Whatever happened…
I think we covered it up ourselves.
O5-1: When you say "ourselves" do you mean—
O5-2: Oh, no I just mean the Foundation.
If we were actually involved, then everyone
here would have those scars, but Six, Nine,
and I definitely don't have them, so that
leads me to believe they didn't drug us.
It would be an all-or-nothing deal.
O5-12: Good work.
Sounds like Eight needs to have a talk with
our Amnestics Department.
O5-8: Wait, wait.
Sorry, I'm still trying to keep all details
in order.
You said they were injected?
O5-2: Yeah.
O5-8: See, that's what I don't get.
We used the injections like, ten years ago?
We moved onto the pills since you can miss
a vein.
Also, I checked our amnestics supply right
after the Caesar event, and we didn't see
any variation from our normal usage.
O5-6: Maybe the records are off?
We've found that whatever Thirteen did, he's
good at covering up his tracks.
O5-8: I don't think that's it.
Because you know who does still use those
injectable amnestics?
The GOC.
O5-12: I see we'll have to schedule another
meeting with our good friends at the UN as
well.
After discussing potential origins for SCP-001,
the Council moved on to the subject of O5-13's
anomalous properties.
The Anomalous Properties Team presented their
findings:
O5-3: Ok… so everyone here has the records
of our measurements, although I can tell you
now, they are not particularly insightful.
O5-10: Do you have too many leads to choose
from?
O5-5: Quite the opposite actually.
We have nothing.
Nothing abnormal with regard to radiation,
humes, radio frequencies.
Thirteen is almost impressively normal.
O5-2: Are you sure we're not going about this
wrong?
I mean, I know we've kind of quantified some
of our anomalies in the past but, as a general
rule they're not supposed to follow the rules,
right?
O5-3: That is what I was beginning to suspect,
although it is troubling that he can just
hide it from us entirely.
O5-5: Or there's the other option - we're
not only barking up the wrong tree, but we're
in the entirely wrong forest.
O5-4: You saying he's not even anomalous in
the first place?
O5-3: It's either that, or we're dealing with
a god.
And a god who knows the Foundation better
than even we do.
O5-1: Let's continue to discuss the non-anomalous
option, since it appears that there would
be very little we could do about the other
case.
O5-9: So, that would mean that he's probably
an inside man for the Insurgency.
O5-11: Or Serpent's Hand.
O5-3: No, not the hand.
They don't operate like this.
O5-2: He might be a Fifthist fanatic.
O5-9: That too.
O5-1: Or maybe he's with someone else.
We've seen quite a bit of the GOC and UIU
popping up in this.
O5-10: My apologies, but I do find it difficult
to believe that a single insurgent would be
able to detonate the on-site nuclear warhead
from half-way across the globe, if we believe
our previous information.
O5-3: I'm not sure we can though.
It sounds like he spoke to our regular body
double.
O5-5: Maybe his anomalous property is that
he can create body doubles?
O5-11: But what are we supposed to do with
that?
O5-12: Excuse me, but I would like to return
to the earlier line of discussion about Thirteen
being unable to perform the assassination
due to possibly meeting with our point of
contact, because I am beginning to believe
that he actually did meet with Thirteen.
O5-5: So, you believe that he was able to
blow Site-01 sky high from halfway across
the globe?
I mean, if we're going with the god theory
I could see it.
O5-12: No, I'm saying he had help.
Or at least more than one man helping him.
Remember how our request to install additional
security cameras was denied by the Ethics
Committee?
O5-6: Did you finally talk to them?
O5-12: I did.
I met with Mr. Huang to demand an explanation.
He refused and told me it was above my security
clearance.
O5-11: Above your security clearance?
You're on the Council, there simply aren't
things "outside of your jurisdiction".
You run the Ethics Committee for goodness
sakes!
O5-12: That's not quite accurate.
I am not in charge of the Ethics Committee,
I'm simply the O5 ambassador to it.
They need to be a separate entity to eliminate
bias in various cases.
O5-1: So, you believe that Thirteen is in
league with the Ethics Committee?
O5-3: Or the Administrator if it's set above
your security clearance.
O5-12: Or both.
Whoever it is, they are trying very hard to
stop us from seeing him in private.
O5-11: Someone should just let us give him
a full physical.
He's probably baseline, this would let us
confirm that.
O5-2: Yeah, but if we're wrong and our "god
theory" is correct, he'll blow our asses sky-high
like the last council.
O5-1: I believe that we need to adjourn here,
so we have enough time to prepare for our
next full Council meeting to avoid suspicion.
Although we do need to expand our search further.
I will consider speaking to Thirteen before
the next conference, but I will only do so
if I believe it will not result in a second
Caesar Incident.
Are there any objections to this?
The council fell silent.
O5-1: Then I believe this conference is dismissed.
Alert!
Retinal scan confirmed.
Identity verified.
Your credentials have been accepted, and further
access has been granted.
Welcome, O5-13.
You have one new message:
"Hello Thirteen,
I’m sure you’ve been keeping tabs on your
fellow Council’s progress.
They’re growing closer than either of us
wanted, but I’m not surprised.
When you get enough smart people together,
they tend to surpass your expectations.
You’re probably hoping this is going to
end soon.
I’m sorry you’ve gone through this, it
obviously wasn’t in our plan for you when
we inducted you into the council.
But, if you could keep up our gambit a little
longer I would be appreciative.
I’m unconvinced your cohorts are ready to
know what happened to their predecessors,
and I don’t want to ask Al Fine and Johnson
to help clean up another May 13th.
I don't even want the thought of pulling a
Caesar Event in their heads.
The GOC and the UIU already have enough dangling
over my head as is.
But if they do approach you, and confront
you about the situation, I’d rather you
have a direct answer.
Also, transcripts tend to be more convincing
than recall.
I’ve attached here the transcript from the
O5 meeting before the "Caesar Incident".
It’s part of the last-minute backup that
Site-01 performed as part of Stage 3 Containment
Breach Protocols.
If anyone asks where those backups are stored,
you can tell them the same thing I told you
– it’s beyond their clearance.
-The Administrator"
O5-1 was present in the O5 Council Conference
Room.
He was working at a laptop in front of him,
beside which sat a cup of coffee.
A message flashed up on the screen, reading:
Access Granted.
You have five minutes to complete an action
before the session automatically shuts down.
He grumbled to himself, irritated.
Two minutes passed before the remaining council
members except for O5-13 entered the room.
O5-1: You're all here!
Great, wouldn't want one of you to be off-site
for this.
O5-4: One, what’s this about?
I know you’ve been going through a phase
lately, but emergency meetings demand a real
emergency.
O5-1: Oh, it’s an emergency alright.
O5-8: Then spit it out.
We have a breach?
New XK level threat?
O5-1: No, it’s more of something under Two’s
jurisdiction.
We have an internal affairs issue.
O5-1 motioned to the coffee.
O5-1: One of you bastards thought I would
actually drink this.
O5-11: Someone didn’t give you enough sugar?
O5-1: No, too much arsenic.
Another message flashed up on the computer,
reading: You have three minutes to complete
an action before the session automatically
shuts down.
O5-8: Do you want to finish with that?
O5-1: That pain-in-the-ass can be patient.
O5-4: Wait, wait.
You think one of us tried to kill you with
your… coffee.
O5-1: Oh, don’t act like that’s below
you.
I know you’ve all been out to bury my ass.
O5-5: One, calm down.
I know we’ve had our differences but—
O5-1: But what?
It’s not like this is the first time one
of you has tried to destroy me.
I know your guys once tried to infiltrate
one of my transports.
O5-5: Infiltrate?
He was assigned to fill in for—
O5-7: It’s no use, Five.
The man can't think straight anymore.
O5-1: Oh really?
Who’s the one here with his head so far
up Marshall’s ass he can taste the caviar?
O5-7: You’re accusing me of selling out?
O5-1: No, no.
I’m accusing all of you of selling out,
or being out for yourself or some nonsense.
You’ve all gone soft.
It used to be ”if it don’t make sense,
throw it in a cage”.
Now it's “let’s measure it, look into
it, figure out what we know, then make sure
it doesn’t bother anyone”.
That’s not containment.
That’s sitting idly and hoping the public
doesn’t find it.
My god, we’ve started outsourcing to pet
shelters!
O5-4: You know, if this is a problem we can
just calm down and rethink our stances on
a few things.
O5-1: That won’t change anything.
Half of you are under someone’s thumb and
the other half of you are so messed up you
need a cell of your own.
O5-7: Says the man who suggested we drink
from the Fountain of Youth.
O5-1: Well, Seven you’re right.
I’m about as far from baseline as the rest
of you.
Like, goddamn it, anomalies are essentially
running this organization.
Ten’s learned how to do magic from the library.
I need to take a whole cocktail of drugs just
to remember Eight exists.
The computer chimed in again, saying: You
have two minutes to complete an action before
the session automatically shuts down.
O5-1: [to the computer] Shut up goddamn it!
O5-10: We're getting off topic.
You said someone poisoned you.
What about Thirteen?
He’s not even here!
O5-1: That’s because I sent him to talk
to Nobody.
O5-10: Why?
O5-1: Because he’s the only one I trust.
He’s the only one I don’t need to have
this chat with.
He’s the only normal person on this whole
god damn Council.
We plucked him off the streets, and just started
asking him “do you think this is weird?”
I’m not worried about someone whose movements
we’ve been able to monitor since he came
out of the uterus.
You freaks— I don’t know what you all
did before you showed up here.
For all I know you’re just eldritch abominations
waiting for the chance to kill me dead.
O5-4: One, slow down.
They were so wrapped up in their argument,
they barely noticed the computer saying: You
have one minute to complete an action before
the session automatically shuts down.
O5-1: And you know what?
We’ve always been pretty liberal with containing
anomalies.
Now we might have twelve of them on the Council.
O5-12: One!
O5-1: What?
O5-12: Your session!
Just finish it already.
It's distracting as all hell.
O5-1: You know… you're right.
I should just finish it already.
There's not much more for me to do.
O5-1 resumed his work at the computer.
O5-1: Aside from containing you, like the
inhuman aberrations you are.
But it was a little too late for that.
The computer, which had been allowed to time
out, said: Emergency Stage 3 Containment Breach
Protocol Activated.
The on-site nuclear warhead will detonate
in 5…4…3…
This concludes the file on SCP-001.
It appears that, in a place dedicated to studying
the strange and unusual, where the bizarre
and anomalous have become the pedestrian,
the usual, just another day at the office,
the most notable thing a person can be...is
completely average.
When the impossible becomes possible, when
you and everyone around you are the furthest
thing from normal, the ordinary is the stuff
of nightmares.
Now go check out “SCP-001 Does Not Exist"
and “SCP-001 - A Simple Toymaker” for
more proposals pertaining to the endless mysteries
of SCP-001.